when it comes to vaccinations in our
state it's going fairly well but there
are still pockets in our community that
need help governor sistelak highlighted
some of those areas today madison
kimbrough is live at the southern nevada
health district and a little bit of a
win this afternoon to tell us more about
their game plan madison
yeah it is very windy out here so six
zip codes were highlighted for having
low vaccination rates as you can see
we're here at the southern nevada health
district and for a good majority living
in those areas they're made up of
minority and socially vulnerable
communities
both fema and the southern nevada health
district have reached into these
communities to try to educate those who
may be hesitant it's still unclear the
reasoning behind the low count but for
many in these areas lack of education
and the language barrier may come into
play many also believe the vaccine is
something you have to buy or show papers
to get jorge viote a community outreach
coordinator for the district says it all
comes down to education we identify
every week
they seek code they are
low
rate they have a low vaccination rate
and what we do with also called we
create a specifically a
pamphlet with the address of the
permanent clinic who are more closer to
the c code we haven't distributed the
last three week ten thousand
flyers already we have another four
thousand today and the office that is
going to start between today and
tomorrow it's important to realize in
all of the low vaccine zip codes there
are clinics nearby
and if you have any questions you can go
to the southern nevada health district
site to look up your location by your
zip code reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now